numero7 solo o in compagnia di nei
cuccioli di voodoo chile e di positano è
arrivato il momento di fare colazione
cosa posso fare per la importa mi una
colazione abile preferenze ma i loro
della colazione o detto certo farò io my
lord velocissima mylord in questo tribù
c'è solo cibo per cani e per gatti e ti
lasciamo speriamo che vada bene ragazzi
forse so cosa preparargli una bomba
cioccolata calda
speriamo mai loro attrezzi polari
l'appunto mylord la colazione è pronta
mi dispiace ma il ordino cui il vino è
una cioccolata calda ma i lord ma deve
aspettare solo un attimo che chiuda i
suoi dolci marshmallow o solo per lei
con un cucchiaio
sto andando a prenderlo vado subito a
prenderla qualcosa insieme
certo mylord subito negato certo ancora
ora scusate ma che si mangia ris a lato
con la cioccolata calda
credo ragazzi orribile ma queste sono le
uniche cose che noi abbiamo in casa di
salato
mi scusi ma il nord è molto calda questa
la cioccolata calda e ora mi svegliai
voi due
subito si subito ragazzi buongiorno
ciao eri c'è già ma i lord mia inviata a
svegliarvi video e l'alfa sto cacchio
harry non ti girare camera che fosse più
adeguata di ruolo per osare
io non so come dirglielo ma non si
vogliono alzare non mai ordo provato in
tutti i modi
le luci dell'alba le chiedo scusa ma in
questi si riuscisse a campare certo mai
nord l'alba è bella ma non quanto mai
lord ti è piaciuto questo sonetto
convinto mainardi non è chiedo scusa
abbiamo un attimo degli scansafatiche
così che hanno detto sto cazzo ma i lord
e loro se entro 5 secondi alzate e non
per i temi che ammettono essi sergente
capitano io di tutto fiori di casa e
tornate fuori 54 presi dagli oneri
servette capitato ho detto sì cari anche
di quanti soldi e fortuna che c'aveva
[Musica]
vediamo i ricchi e che un giorno non lo
sono tenute o numero berlino perché
avete fatto qua per la cucina a hugo
a parole ma non è una cosa così divagava
che ti sei fatto
ma queste sono importanti e dei tuoi
bando una borsa noi mai visto il video
io l'effetto del sesso in cambio del
denaro e lei avrà rifiutato i soldi non
possono pagare il buon gusto
milano city subito meno mi dava un'aria
di di comando guai essendo forza
mostrano il giorno sono gli auguri della
roccia mohsen e di zuccheri ci sono ma
senza così credi che chi 66 sull'europa
e primo toluca max o cavalcatore di
toluca
niente ma tutto è quello lì dicono
cromato di contento faremo l'attimo ma
scusa ma quali sono dei selvaggi nel
fatto che ti sembro matto
andiamo in una versione si sta giocando
ma la vera vittima vieni qui mi scappa
da quello lì che guardava vuole essere
molto molto occupato quanto è quello lì
di avatar
diventa quello che poi un attimo
trasformista schiavizzata è tale quando
i piatti delle grazie mista una
canzoncina nel mondo bene non usa la
rivista usa rimane stabile quindi a
farvi corri a buttare questi sacchi non
mandare dalle sue parti in segmenti tu
che stai facendo e dopo abbandona la
flog validi punta anche la carta e visto
che ci sei butta anche te stesso perché
a me arpiona si vede che sia una brutta
persona mi vuole bene a doveva buttare
anche queste che mela diventato un bravo
volto e ora andiamo a rompersi che
parliamo giovane don marco sbrigati a
portare via tutto quanto non ho
ma sento che costella e fracchia mettere
il vecchio e adesso lascia cadere il
trasformista senza uno midili per le
gambe piacere di campo se ne è convinto
di avermi sotto scacco
ma io sono un totti pugnale nero il mio
cesare alle spalle e quindi quali che
canti per lei signor e corazze che cosa
vuole che leganti my lord de scrivimi
con un canto
insomma che me fai la cortesia di
sistema la lettiera che fa veramente
dato il bagno pulsano e merda de cardona
vedersi a me ne frega bettina sì ma vai
a spalare la merda e subito mylord cioè
questa juve non riesce a fare tutti con
nessuno ci credi che se fondiamo il bus
club di calcio faticano a fare punti
gli elementi di una 0
mamma mia create le famose gare
poco cambia
finito il primo tempo dammi il tocco sul
braccio della fortuna maiale porta
fortuna mi sta chiamando guglielmo che
stare nell'altra stanza e quindi un
[ __ ] errico ancu lo dico la matrice
spalle stasera no ma questo è stato per
me per moggi bonucci ivolution c al
novantesimo al minuto 90 mamma mia
finisce la partita 2 a 1 partorito 9
chili di ansia non ha capito io so pensa
ora capisco cosa si prova a partorire
bensì cava in e pure il tocco di e
valentina ha portato fortuna grande vale
il successo che è successo beh bagno
qualcuno ha rotto il dovere di occhio a
camminare edicole che cosa qualcuno ai
capelli rosa con le ciabatte
ti consiglio di andare a partita che
sono sei ore per fare una massa mourinho
voglio era ma stanno velocità a prendere
basilico youtube evitare che mi fai
vedere parti ok
quando poi dovremmo andare clip va in
prima clip sto andando da vale a
ringraziarla per la cena che ci ha fatto
ma ovviamente fingerò strapparle un
sorriso no non me ne frega niente
il tutto lo scoprirà soltanto quando
uscirà il video perché non le farò
vedere la vittima quindi vabbè vale gesù
non mangiano tutti grazie che vale
veramente guarda che bel lavoro che hai
fatto
faccio una carrellata no
ci vuole tanta gamba donna facciamo che
fa grazie a le grazie
io ho paura che cosa stiamo facendo
perché mira e hanno mai cucinato per
tutti veramente stasera sikania io ti
faccio i complimenti
oggi abbiamo imboccato una giornata
buona mi hai dato il tocco della
vittoria della juve andando troppo un
piatto di pasta che apprezzo molto
bagnato su su come che si diceva vita
capitale ragazzi voglio di the vip
italia fatecelo sapere se sotto capitare
a te lo conosce dpp dare complimenti a
mamma mia vale hiranaka mille guardate
guardate i piatti degli altri circuiti
guardano vari demoliti inizierete a
volermi bene no l'america casa
raga com'era questo assaggio di pasta
buona cosa vale per buttarle
l'arena del resto dai maya subito ma
possono comunque era squisita ed ai baci
la ricetta mai mai è segreto di nonna
non può pensare cosa io poi vira ricetta
se vuoi come militare non esiste da
forno pp aree con una sola t che quindi
questa vicenda due tipi chinaglia
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa puntata spero che sia piaciuta
fatecelo sapere qua sotto mettete un
pollice in su
noi ci vediamo domani alle 14 per
un'altra uncut ai blog massa altrimenti
alle 19 sul social viola